there is an entire body of knowledge
here
trying to figure out why men aren't
getting laid
yeah yeah yeah um i think
that i mean that that definitely sort of
is at least to me a very
charitable uh probably one of the more
charitable
you know interpretations i've seen it's
a backhanded way of doing it yeah
right but but yeah i mean there are a
lot of guys out there who are struggling
i know guys like this
who aren't doing so well um in terms of
dating in terms of
jobs you know they're not where they
want to be and
yeah they're struggling and you know i i
don't i don't think guys like you or
anything
like tying tying women up or anything
like that you know in terms of keeping
them out of out of the dating
pool but i do think there are some
challenges
right now simply because the modern
world is
you know there's a mismatch between our
sort of
innate desires and the way that the
modern world is set up
um such that you know there aren't as
many men in college and women tend to
prefer
educated men but you know men aren't
going to college and
you know people are wondering why that
is um there aren't as many
you know men who are earning uh in in
terms of the millennial generation i
believe that women are earning as much
and in some cases even more
than millennial men um at least in the
uk i read this
so you guys are better educated richer
women yes women are better educated and
richer which again is
you know there's nothing wrong with that
but if they're looking for
male partners they're going to look for
men who are also better educated and
richer and preferably even
more educated and richer than themselves
so this is now becoming the tall friend
right they're becoming the tall friend
who can only date basketball players
and you know like pro sports guys
because
and and the the converse of that is
really really bad
for both men and women which is
the alternative if women tend to date up
in a cross or they their preference is
to date opened across
to richer and or better educated men
and there are fewer of those men around
there's two choices left which is
both genders get to remain single for
the rest of their life
or women get into relationships with men
that they're fundamentally unattracted
to
which is also not ideal right i mean
well there's also
the other option would be
women can park women can essentially
share a man
right um so so some people have
speculated uh
that this is what's basically going on
in these gender imbalanced
um communities like like universities
uh in colleges where there's a surplus
of women relative to men
men are much more likely to play the
field so to speak you know they're
more more reluctant to settle down more
interested in casual sex and so on
and in colleges where there are more
men than women there's actually more
relationships
uh more emotional commitment and more of
a dating culture
and some people find this surprising but
it's really not because in these
colleges with more men their
men are basically competing to to
uh you know get a get a girlfriend and
women on average tend to prefer
you know courtship commitment
relationships and so on
and in environments where there are more
women than men
uh women basically have to compete for
the small pool
of men and what do men like well men on
average tend to
like you know more casual situations you
know more
short-term relationships one-night
stands um
you know things that are more casual and
so women are more likely to do those
things to try to get men to
to like them so they've got to play each
other's game right when
right men are the surplus rather than
the scarcity they have to play women's
game and when women are the surplus
rather than the scarcity they have to
play men's game
right yeah and we're seeing we're seeing
a kind of inversion i mean i think in
the past
when men have more education than women
maybe it was maybe maybe monogamy was
easier uh in some ways simply because
you know if men or if yeah if women
prefer dating men who
are educated and have high earnings and
so on relative to themselves
then yeah i think maybe it was easier
back then
uh in some ways and today when things
are sort of flipped and they're the
reverse now where women have more
education and so on than men
uh becomes harder and so some people
have suggested that
polygamy or some variation of that
will arise
you